ANJALI SASTRY: Part
of our challenge
as teachers is to help make
sure that we're embedding
into their approach
enough rigor,
that we're looking at
the data and the evidence
and that it's being linked
to the content we're
teaching here.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
in the podcast,
we're looking at a new
kind of independent study.
ANJALI SASTRY: Teaching this
way is incredibly rewarding
and also really scary.
You'll often be
invited into domains
where you don't
have the expertise,
and it's quite
hard to predict how
a given session or
conversation will go.
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome
to Chalk Radio,
a podcast about inspired
teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
In this episode,
we'll be talking
about action learning
and an exciting evolution
of the independent study.
The MIT Sloan
School of Management
has a tradition of involving
MBA Fellows in collaborations
with partners from
around the globe.
For years, these projects
have helped participants build
experience and connections.
And these students,
the MBA Fellows,
are often already
established in a career
or in building
their own projects.
My guest today,
Dr. Anjali Sastry,
has led over 100 groups of
MBA Fellows in these projects.
Now the thing to note here
is that these projects were
developed by the
school and instructors,
and students would sign
on to work on them.
But Dr. Sastry wanted to
get students more invested
right from the
start, so she decided
to do something a
little different.
We'll pick up with Dr.
Sastry's explanation.
ANJALI SASTRY: This last
year, I tried a new experiment
where, instead of us
bringing in the projects,
I had students work with
me to create the projects
they were interested in that
spoke to societal challenges
that would be important
in the coming decade
and that also linked to
technology in some way.
Students come in with
a passion or a set
of questions they're really
interested in investigating.
Could we take some
of the things that
work in action learning,
traditional action learning
classes, and bend them
towards that kind of drive?
Could I use my own
connections, relationships,
Rolodex to help students
follow their passions
but also to find thought
partners or project
partners in the
world and also tap
into my own expertise and
that of other MIT faculty
as well as their peers?
SARAH HANSEN: Could
you talk a little bit
about some of the specific
projects that students did?
ANJALI SASTRY: The projects
students did ranged greatly,
but all had as a theme using
what they were learning here
and tapping into emerging or
existing technology in new ways
to find solutions to
problems that face many.
One of my students, Alini,
came to MIT completely on fire
with this idea of tapping
into analytics and AI
to solve what she saw
as a major challenge
when it came to bringing
finance to smallholder
and small-scale farmers.
She's an expert on
agricultural finance.
And she realized that in her
native Brazil and elsewhere,
people who didn't have good
credit standing and good credit
records, farmers who
didn't have those assets,
couldn't get loans and
were forever locked out.
So there's a big dichotomy
between the people who have
access to finance
and those who don't.
Could she break down
that barrier in some way?
Could new forms of data and
technology help do that?
So instead of relying only
on somebody's credit record,
could you look at the weather,
their farming choices,
their behaviors,
and physical data
and use it to come
up with a better
assessment of the riskiness of
a given farmer from the lender's
point of view?
Slightly technical
area, but it actually
has huge implications
because it could
open the door to
all kinds of folks
who are excluded from
traditional finance
by providing other
methods of sorting out
their riskiness and
their credit worthiness.
So she's got drone data, map and
weather data, behavioral data,
transactional data, and
is trying to stitch it
all up in new ways.
SARAH HANSEN: Each
of these projects
required significant time and
engagement from Dr. Sastry.
I couldn't help but ask
how this all worked.
What did it look
like to be involved
with each student's project?
ANJALI SASTRY: Each
project was customized.
And one of the
things I've learned
about trying to innovate
when it comes to teaching
is you have to be
willing to invest
a lot the first few rounds,
the first few years you
do something.
And then over
time, you learn how
to make it a little more
efficient, streamlined,
and maybe scalable and
more cost-effective.
I learned I had to
keep a whiteboard up
in my office with each
project and each person,
because I had over a dozen
running, to keep them straight
and try to remember who's doing
what so that when I saw it
when I came into the office,
that person would be on my mind
or that project
would be on my mind.
I do think, mundane
as it sounds,
I think it's also important to
have good forms and paperwork.
SARAH HANSEN: Sure.
ANJALI SASTRY:
Having people really
articulate in writing
briefly what they want to do
and having a structured
update process
really helps keep the
momentum and build the focus.
SARAH HANSEN: How do you measure
success in projects like this?
ANJALI SASTRY: That's
a great question
because students who are
following their passions really
get into it.
You give them
enough freedom, they
will have a good time, right?
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
ANJALI SASTRY: But part of our
challenge as their teachers
is to help make sure that we're
embedding into their approach
enough rigor, that we're looking
at the data and the evidence
and that it's being linked
to the content we're
teaching here.
So a passion project by itself
may or may not be academic.
Not every student who comes
in with their passion project
is necessarily going to
want to or should turn it
into an in-depth study.
So I've learned that you
can't convert everyone.
And that's OK because
we're offering--
this is an offering
of a new learning
experience that's
very much driven
by the students' interest.
You need to really
be able to allow
the students to self-select in.
It's hard to offer something
like this as a requirement.
So that's another piece is
striking the right balance
between opening the
door and inviting people
in versus cracking the whip
and following up on them.
SARAH HANSEN: Dr. Sastry
pointed to one of the challenges
that she faced in taking on
these students' projects,
and it's one that many
instructors face at some point.
How far would she go outside
her area of expertise
to support her students?
ANJALI SASTRY: I need to be
able to figure it out for myself
and then also be very
clear with the students.
How much do I know
about the blockchain?
That's not an area
of my research.
So how far do I want to
go down a set of projects
that take that on?
I'm interested in this topic.
I'll learn with you, but
my domain of expertise
relates to these areas.
We can apply it
to your questions.
We can apply systems thinking
or organizational change
or business models to the
questions you're articulating.
But I am not the technical
expert on this domain,
so you'll need to work
with someone else on that.
And different instructors
have different interests
in stepping out of
their comfort zone.
So I think that's
really important.
Another big question
is, how willing are you,
as an instructor, to have
a mishmash of projects that
take on very different domains?
Teaching this way is
incredibly rewarding and also
really scary.
You'll often be
invited into domains
where you don't
have the expertise,
and it's quite
hard to predict how
a given session or a
conversation will go.
It's not like running a case
where you know the story
and you know what you're going
to say at each moment in class
or you've at least got a sense
of what that might look like.
Because very often, students
will come in and say,
I've totally changed my mind.
And you have to deal with that.
So there's both the
kind of personal journey
of learning that's
less predictable
and the domain part
that's less predictable.
But you, as the
instructor, get to set
some of those parameters.
So I want them to
not simply make
general arguments about
what should happen
but to think about
what they could
do as a leader, an
entrepreneur, and executive.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in learning more
about social impact
technology projects
or independent studies, you
can find Dr. Sastry's teaching
materials on our
site at ocw.mit.edu.
You'll also find videos
of Dr. Sastry's students
sharing their insights
about their own projects.
Additional materials and
Instructor Insights about
project-based learning
are on our educator portal
at ocw.mit.edu/educator.
As always, thank you
so much for listening.
We'd love for your
OCW story to become
a part of our conversation.
Use the contact link
in the show notes
to share how you use OCW to
shape your own life or those
of others.
Your story will inspire
us and other people
and will help us
continue to share
the kind of open
educational resources
that make a difference.
Until next time, I'm Sarah
Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare.